ausländer wo warst du als der überfall
passierte uh ich war nicht in der abteilung meiner tochter unklar
ein bisschen
links von da haben
sie entschieden
das ich alleine bin und es
besser ist zusammen
zu sein deswegen hast du überlebt sonst hast du
wahrscheinlich ich habe überlebt weil
Weil das mein Bruder ist
und ich manchmal hier geschlafen habe.
Was denkst du, sollten Deutschland und der
Westen tun, um der Ukraine
zu helfen, sie müssen uns helfen,
sie
müssen uns helfen, zu überleben, und
ich denke,
die ganze Welt
muss dieses Verbrechen stoppen,
diese Drohnen
sind  noch beschrifteter
Schacht schließt den Vlog